In the previous quiz questions,
you used your intuition to read
through some if else statements.
You figured out what different
messages would be printed to the logs
based on certain conditions.
Now let's look into these
statements more formally.
If/else statements are called
control flow statements.
It's named this way because instead of
a linear flow of code where one line of
code is being executed after another,
the control flow statement actually
allows us to jump to different parts of
the code based on certain conditions.
So if this condition is true,
meaning the Boolean variable
was set to true up here somewhere,
then these statements will be executed.
And it will skip this block of code.
If this condition is false,
then we execute these lines of code, and
then resume the normal linear
flow of code after that.
Looking at our vocab word glossary,
we can look up the phrase
if/else statement.
One way to think about this is to
use an analogy of a train track.
A train track has a switch so
that given a certain condition,
the train will go one way or the other.
Similarly in the if/else statement,
if this condition is true,
then we'll execute one path of code.
If the statement is false, then we'll
execute a different path of code.
And then afterwards, we're going to
resume the normal flow of code.
The if statement is the simplest
control flow statement.
Notice the syntax here.
We start with the word if, and then we
have parentheses around the condition.
And then we have an opening brace, and
then a closing brace at the end
of that if block of code.
In this example of a pizza ordering app,
if the user wants the order to be
delivered to their home, then we're
going to adjust the price to add five
extra dollars for the delivery charge.
Otherwise, if the order is not for
delivery, then we just
skip this line of code, and we don't
add the extra charge for delivery.
Then in these subsequent lines of code,
we can use the totalPrice
variable with the correct value.
Now the if/else statement
is a little more advanced.
If the condition in
the parentheses is true,
then we execute these lines of code.
Then we skip this and
then continue with the rest of the code.
So in this game app,
if the user has zero points,
then we're going to update
the textView to say Loser.
And we're going to update
the imageView to be a sad face.
However, if the condition is false,
the person has, for example, 100 points,
then we're going to skip
this block of code, and
we're going to go down
here to the else case.
We're going to update the textView
to show the word Winner, and
then we're going to update
the imageView to show a happy face.
Then we're going to continue
with these lines of code here.
As you can see, the code inside the if
statement can contain as many lines of
code as we want,
similarly with the else statement.
If we want more than two possible code
paths, we can use an else if statement.
You can have as many else
if blocks as you want,
and then you could just end
with an else at the very end.
But again, all these else if and
else blocks are optional.
In our code here, we can fall into one
of three possible cases depending on
the value of the integer
variable itemCount.
itemCount just represents the number of
items in the shopping cart in our app.
Let's start with the first condition.
If itemCount is 12, then 12 is
greater than 10, so that is true.
And then we would execute the lines
of code within this block of code.
We would create a Toast message
that says, You get 20% off, and
show it at the bottom of the screen.
Since we fell into this case, then we
skip this block and this block, and
then we continue with
the rest of the code.
What would happen if the shopping
cart only had two items in it?
Well, then itemCount would
not be greater than ten.
So this would be false, and we would
skip this block of code here and
then jump down to the else if statement.
Then we would check if two is
greater than zero, and it is,
so then we would fall into this case.
We would show a Toast message that says,
Thank you.
Since we fell into this case,
we're going to skip this one, and
then we can continue with
the rest of the code.
And lastly if our shopping
cart had zero items,
then this condition would be false
because zero is not greater than ten.
This condition would be false because
zero is not greater than zero.
And then we would fall
into this else case here.
And we would show a message that says,
You have an empty cart.
If you ever need a reminder of
the syntax of any of these statements,
you can just check the official
Java documentation.
It tells you about the if statement,
and here's an example.
And then it also shows you that if
else statement and here's the example.
And lastly there is an example
with else if statements.
Based on everything that
I've shown you so far,
you're probably realizing that Java has
a special use for the words if and else.
They're Java keywords and they're used
to control how the code is executed.
So you can't use these
as variable names.
>From the examples that I showed you, you
also may have started to realize that we
put different expressions in
this test condition here.
Any expression is valid as long
as evaluates to true or false.
So we can put a Boolean variable in
the test condition or, for example,
we can compare two values.
We can compare two values using any of
these equality and relational operators.
We can test that two images
are equal to each other, or
not equal to each other, or greater or
less than equal to each other.
And here are examples of
different test conditions.